hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic and since
its very creation the Internet has
opened the doors for so many
possibilities jobs entertainment forums
the social media the internet has no
doubt changed the world yet out of all
these possibilities there is one
undeniable fact that will always remain
the same the internet is full of pricks
complainers trolls people who live to
force their opinion onto your opinion
whether they have any idea what they're
talking about or not they're pretty
pathetic and they show no sign of going
away anytime soon and there's just so
many of these goddamn idiots that's hard
to properly deal with them in the best
way possible
why insult these brainless dimwits when
we would be proud to insult them for you
Channel awesome and blit proudly present
these salts video responses for when you
just don't have time to deal with these
mental three-year-olds we had video
responses for whiners that Chatwin guy
he doesn't pay it Goku I'm sorry I'm
having a real hard time understanding
you um here's someone who better speak
your way-hey responses for ramblers who
just need more attention you're so
stupid I bet you don't even know what
puberty is have you hit puberty yet
idiot you are so smart screw everyone
god you're better than you please tell
me more everything you need when you
just don't have the energy to listen to
any more insecure morons
and that's time you're trying to say
something smart let me know because I
gotta record it on my iPhone girl
locate them at blips YouTube channel and
start using them today because by god
you have a life to live and I hate
everything you know what I hate
Microsoft - they don't ex Sony Linux is
where it's at Glee's pretty good show
but you know it's